I think I did good evening ladies and
gentlemen welcome to planning West my
name's Justin courage I am the chair we
are being recorded we're not live but we
are being recorded so if you don't want
to be recorded come and see a member of
the team here the committee team to let
them know this is a public meeting but
it is not for public participation
unless you have registered to speak if I
can before we go on to the first matters
ask the officers to introduce themselves
on banks from committee services major -
legal services manager in my role as an
impartial adviser to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the art EPI
planning committee members are not bound
by the case officers recommendation or
by oral advice thank you Jeff Louise
come on Senior Planner
Paul Reeves environmental health
great thank you ah now in a break from
the published agenda I will just like to
invite our previous chair cancer cargill
who chaired this committee for I don't
know he'll probably tell us just to say
a few words thank you very much and it's
four years three years as a chair and
welcome to chairing the committee as
pleasurable experiences for me in the
last three years I've really enjoyed my
time on the committee and I look forward
to seeing some excellent decisions from
this committee going forward I do
remember the first the first perhaps he
was even the first committee I chaired
we had 40 members of the public opposed
to on particular application I think
you've got quite a few here this evening
as well and I must admit I did get
called a few names at night but such is
life
we've had to make some difficult
decisions over the times and but I think
all good decisions and we've been rarely
challenged on them and I think that is a
credit to the committee and the the
process and the thoroughness that they
go through only on the applications as I
said good policy decisions based upon
other good decisions based on policy and
are very very proud to have been part of
this committee that's it I just want to
say thank you very much indeed for all
the support that I've had especially
from the offices and also from the from
the members as well okay thank you very
much chairman thank you very much mark
thank you
apologies for absence chairman apologies
from councillor Giles apologies from
councillor Atkinson Terhune councillor
brain is substituting and apologies from
counselors Audrey
disclosure of interest to anybody
Thank You chair I took number eight and
the old cottage in Brookside that is in
my ward I will be exercising my right to
speak as walk member okay thank you
a member of Old Town Council I don't sit
on the Ulster Town Council Planning
Committee and I've had no involvement
with this application so you will be
sitting oh great thank you I've had a
number of emails today from various
things on different yes great minutes
asked oh sorry I didn't see you can also
write item six seven and nine I'm the
ward member and I'll be speaking so I'd
be taking part great thank you just
gates of cancer plane please go up the
letters was it you bombs it's totally
the same ones that I've had them from I
have one srg roof space yep another one
I have photographs from the snitterfield
as well from the instability yeah sorry
I didn't so there are significant
updates if you want to read through
those
if you're misunderstood and now we'll
adjourn for five minutes while you read
okay thank you very stop working so on
with the agenda what I'm going to do is
bring forward item number 11 to 2 now if
you want to move forward it's the
footpath 1 right right at the end the
parish council have removed their
objection so we can vote to delegate
that to officers we are care to delegate
that are proposing that can I have a
seconder for that second of my brain can
we vote on that too okay okay so that's
that and then we go back to the running
order which is application 1703 zero
eight nine SI t roof space in ulster
heath and allison is going to tell us
about that sorry Louise thank you thank
you to the application site identified
by the black dot on the map is located
in Ulster and lies the west of the
Birmingham Road and to the east of the
Ulster he throwed the application site
is outlined in red on the plan and the
plan shows the site in context with the
surrounding built form broad Heath
leisure and business is located in this
area here and the residential dwelling
known as high trees which lies
immediately east of the site residential
development lies to the north and open
land lies to the west and the
residential dwelling no meanness Heath
Vale and Turnpike offices light to the
south
that's he fail that's that property
there the site lies within the West
Midlands Greenbelt and a number of
public footpaths are identified by the
hatched green lines on the plan all
located in the vicinity of the site the
site operates as a general industrial
use specializing in the manufacture of
roof timbers raw materials which timber
perils and finished products such as
roof panels and wall panels roof trusses
are stacked around the periphery of the
site and the factor building is utilized
for the manufacturing process for the
timber trusses the this application
seeks to erect a single-story extension
onto part of the northern elevation of
the factory its proposed to measure six
point six meters in height with a floor
area of two hundred and twenty nine
point nine square meters the building is
proposed to serve as an acoustic lobby
to assist in reducing noise breakout
noise emanating from the factory when
the existing automated roller shutter
doors open and close the proposal is
going to be constructed from a profiled
plastic coated composite cladding on its
walls and roof and proposed to match the
existing building with an automated
shutter door on its eastern elevation
this is the Eastern elevation here which
is proposed to interlock with the
existing roller sheeter door on the
northern elevation its proposed that
this will ensure that one door is
constantly kept shut at at all times and
both our shirts we're not in use
the application also seeks to revise the
operating hours of the business which
currently is restricted to Monday to
Friday 7:00 until 6:00 p.m. they are
seeking to increase this to 7 p.m. to 9
p.m. Monday to Friday within the service
yard and 7 p.m. to 11 p.m.
within the factory in addition they are
seeking to operate between 7 & 1 p.m. on
Saturdays storage areas are located out
so restricted at present around the
periphery of the site in the area's
locators here at present they are
restricted to a maximum height over six
point two meters and members may recall
an application which sought to increase
the height of of the entirety of the
periphery back early Luxor later last
year and there is proposed to be a
loading area within the center of the
site and at present lime trees are
locators along the entrance to the site
here this is proposed to be enhanced and
with existing planting to be replanted
elsewhere
within the site primarily enhancing the
planting along the other area to the
left of the entrance additional planting
within the Birmingham Road boundary as
well this the applicants have submitted
a very recent plan just before the
meeting this evening which I'm not able
to provide members basically we are
going to be assessing that separately
and it's proposed to be controlled via a
condition which is attached on the
update sheet the green circles within
the site denotes lighting which is
existing lighting and the application
and
as proposed will seek to review the
lighting as part of condition eight and
restrict lighting also flood lighting to
nine o'clock Monday to Fridays and 1
o'clock
on Saturdays with only security lighting
permitted after these hours as a
consequence of these up these proposals
the applicant is also proposing to leave
open the entrance gates to the service
yard during the operating hours that is
within the service yard operate
operating hours a waiting area is also
now identified in the green hatched area
here for two hdvs whilst loading space
for the four vehicles is provided within
the center of the site I'm also advised
that the majority of the finished
product will be stored off-site in
another factory however this doesn't
form part of the application and
therefore can't be attributed wait
turning now to some photographs of the
sites this is a view of the northern
gable of the factory here where there's
existing racking which is proposed to be
removed as a consequence of the
extension and this is the existing
landscaping around the periphery this is
the photograph of the existing role of
shuttered doors and the pedestrian door
to the side both of which would be
contained within the extension this is a
view looking northwards along to the
northern boundary so the extension is
behind here this is a view from within
the offices looking along the Birmingham
Road and the existing tree planting and
then this is a view from the Birmingham
Rose looking at the access gates with
the existing tree planting along the
entrance the service this is within the
service yard so there is racking behind
here and the extension would be to this
this side here
fine sorry this is a view again looking
northwards along the Birmingham Road so
you can start to appreciate the Vista
although this is taken when the the
trees are in leaf these are primarily
deciduous trees as well so the site has
become more exposed in the winter
periods this is a looking a few
southwards along the Ulster Heath Road
so the site is contained within here
again it isn't fully for to appreciate
that and then this is a view of the
entrance from the Ulster Heath Road
where the vehicles park there are number
of updates as the chair has identified
including the omission of condition six
which is no longer required because of
the removal of the racking in that
particular area concerned by that
condition is going to be removed as a
consequence of the extension in addition
there is an additional condition
proposed requiring the installation of
CCTV cameras in order to monitor both
the roller sheeter doors the access
gates and can also show the servants of
the loading area how that is functioning
and also there's a number of amendments
to the wordings tightening in some of
the conditions chairman the
recommendation is to grant planning
permission subject to the revised
wording of the conditions detailed and
the committee report deletion of
condition six and inclusion of condition
19 and the remaining conditions and
notes is outlined in the committee
report thank you
Thank You Louise
great so
we can hear from the parish the town
council now actually this austere town
council cancer clive nails Sturgis
so you've probably done this before just
press the button and speak quite away
away from it you'll have three minutes
and we'll give you a 30-second warning
at the end Thank You chairman can
everybody hear me adequate yes
good evening on counter clown ale stairs
I'm chairman of the Old Town Council
Planning Committee and thank you for
allowing us to voice our objection I
won't be briefing to the point as to of
our three points are covered in the
comprehensive offices report
ATC listened to the residents concerns
at its meeting on the 9th of April 2018
and largely agreed we had previously
been on the site visit following one of
the earlier applications ATC's objection
covers three basic points on none of
which s IG compliant with the
requirement and planning application and
all of which are in reasonable core do
the residents concerns and the officers
recommendations they are noise lighting
and landscaping concerns over lighting
are covered in the offices report
sections para 50 para 5 page 14 and
recommendation 8 can our concerns over
landscaping are covered in the officers
report sections para paragraph 7 page 10
and recommendation 12 ITC supports all
conditions in the office of the report
including the updates with one exception
that being there is no condition on a
proper consolidated noise report the
inadequacy of the noise report is as
follows the night report is actually not
relevant to this application it is
out-of-date and refers to an earlier
vacation it is boat confused and
confusing it does not refer to the new
working hours in this amendment nor does
it refer to the possible effects of the
new airlock extension item three of the
summary states I quote the external
Yards operations are highly likely to
have an adverse effect on neighboring
residential properties SDC's
Environmental Health Officer I quote
highlights disappointments that the
noise report is based on a previous
report paragraph 3 page 10 expresses
caution and conditions of working hours
to be reduced from 2300 to 2130 seconds
it is our contention that a valid
consolidated noise report as requested
by both the Environmental Health Officer
and ATC
should be a further conditional
application and not to be completed
until the airlock is operational and
under winter conditions thank you Jim
thank you very much can I just clarify
you're kind of okay with the lighting
and landscape aspects now but you still
have worries about the noise yes
chairman the as far as we can determine
the recommendations on landscaping and
lighting would satisfy our basic
concerns fundamental concern is that the
noise report is not relevant okay thank
you and before we go - the bars
you want you want a condition for a new
up-to-date report and what would be the
point of that if we've granted
permission as
sorry as I understand it the current
application with the environmental
health officers recommendation is
restricted to 2100 hours not 2300 hours
and at one way of getting around the
problem I suppose but we still don't
know what effect this planned extension
airlock is going to mean to the resident
and it was a condition of the planning
application that that can talk
consolidated noise report was carried
out it wasn't okay thank you
cancel the bonds for questions to start
with this is sort of similar mr.
chairman what I was going to ask for are
you getting a constant or every six
months report on the noise and that's
really what you want is that right and
up-to-date as well yes the previous
report is two years out of date it
doesn't refer to this application at all
doesn't refer to the air if you had a
constant we would like they consolidate
in noise report to be conducted the air
lock has been implemented any other
questions thank you very much and if we
can now hear from I think it's Bob Laila
a neighbor with might drink water as
well I understand that might drink water
will be here to just answer questions
but that's fine say you have three
minutes mr. Laidlaw and at two and a
half we'll give a 30-second warning if
you could
press the press the button next Cyprus
this side shows what was proposed in the
original application everything a low
level to maintain openness and this was
the basis for its approval the next
slide shows what happened high level
stacking everything about the entire
yard if granted this permission will
enable a 50% increase in production and
associated activities on the site and it
will extend production into the quieter
evening and weekend periods the sound
report highlights the uncertainty of the
measurements and calculations and ends
with a complete disclaimer of the
outcomes previous sound assessments do
underestimate the actual noise levels
because they conclude that there will be
little disturbance to the neighbors but
the residents are disturbed and
therefore to us the report is not
realistic
the environmental officer has stated
that the single consolidated acoustic
report needs to be submitted and we
agree with that an up-to-date more
appropriate sound report is required
next slide please
this application depends on the road
noise to mask the factory noise and this
graph shows the traffic flow along the
adjacent a4 3/5 Road throughout the day
the applicant wants to extend production
into the quiet hours when the traffic
has subsided and that shown by the
right-hand side of the graph this will
cause greater disturbance to the
neighbourhood and is critical to the
application next Cyprus this side shows
how no traffic management plan led to a
lorry queuing on the main road
clearly a safety concern an adequate
traffic management plan has not yet been
presented the plan should provide
quantitative detail of the movement on
and off site and of the higher
production level this informations also
needed to feed into the noise
assessments without this date of the
application cannot be assessed
adequately the operator has continually
breached the conditions and has a
history of non-compliance imposing new
conditions is meaningless unless the
operator complies with them the new
conditions will need to be monitored and
enforced 30 seconds as a summary of the
residents views there is inadequate
information to enable a proper
assessment of the intrusion it will have
an even greater impact on the Greenbelt
area it will have increased adversity
noise and visual impacts on the
residents it will increase the risk of
highway safety incidents and it already
has a big impact on the character of
King's cotton our objection is supported
by the Town Council our ward
councilmember sue Adams and the Ulster
Civic Society and we thank them for
their support thank you very much
questions ok thank you for that you
alluded to a number of breaches of
planning control have they been reported
appropriately and if they have what have
been the outcomes of that I don't think
they've all been reported appropriately
but there's some of them have we've had
a lighting breaches where we've had high
level third lights shone into our
bedroom now perhaps we should have
reported it officially but we actually
my wife phoned up sig roof space
secretary and they did something about
it and we've even had one of their
operatives in our bedroom on the
telephone because somebody yes and they
I'm not sure if we can do this but we do
have our environmental ok good
supplement that because I don't want the
impression I think the question ok good
that was question any other questions
thank you so now we have the agent for
the applicant Richard Irving ah who has
six minutes if he wants it and we also
have the the managing director who were
allowing to sit in to answer questions
as well thank you six minutes 30 seconds
at the end chair members of the
committee my name is Richard Irving and
I've been acting on behalf of si G roof
space since the company first took
occupation of the Abby Mills industrial
unit in 2015 and I'm joined by mr. Kevin
Sherlock who's the managing director and
followed in a short presentation we are
more than happy to answer any questions
you may have
clearly the description of the
development is evident on the front page
of the committee report with consent
being sought for a new site extension to
the northern elevation of the principal
building and a variation of the
operational hours on the consent
approved last year chair without stating
the obvious there is a specific reason
this application has been made and that
is simply the overwhelming success of
the company since it took occupation
some three years ago house building has
continued to grow and this has had a
significant impact on the business and
their ability to manufacture and deliver
the finished roof product to meet orders
and on time the company has grown
significantly and now employs in the
region of 250 staff and will look to
employ a further 80 staff at happy Mills
and a further 50 staff at a second site
to which I refer later this application
before it was submitted was the subject
of detailed discussions with the
planning case officer and environmental
health alongside your highways engineers
to deliver a scheme that would create
space to improve productivity through
the increase in hours but importantly
and at the same time respect
central amenity for those residing near
the site chair just a disjuncture I
would like to pick up on some of the
points raised in the officers report in
relation to comments raised by
objectives on the Parish Council in
respect of concern over noise as this
extension will improve on the current
situation which and misses important
distress is not and has never been
regarded as a statutory nuisance when a
complaints been made the company has
reacted immediately in responding to the
local planning authority either by
return or by examining the complaint and
responding the very next day on a
handful of occasions the main door on
the northern elevation has jammed in an
open position and that has always being
quickly rectified and moved to the
closed position an internal operations
stop until fixed as was witnessed today
by the Environmental Health Officer
following a spot visit the company has
always sought to ensure residential
amenity is an utmost consideration and
indeed when one local resident raised
concern about the external lighting and
that has just been mentioned just now
the company immediately went round noted
that one of the lights had been knocked
out of position and immediately
rectified this the company has always
maintained an open house policy that
anyone can make contact and they can
either come to the site or
representatives of the company like
Kevin will go around immediately as
you'll note from the officers report the
extension will provide further
protection as a new roller shut the door
on the new extension will not open until
the existing roller shutter door which
will now be inside is closed
this not only therefore allows for
further storage space but also a further
noise attenuation measure Jerry will
also note from the officers report and
as part of the expansion program the
company is in the process of acquiring a
further factory unit assuming approval
is received tonight as referred to
previously where 85% of the finished
stock will be stored this will therefore
allow heavy goods vehicles to be fully
loaded rather than partially loaded at
present and therefore there will be no
increase in truck movement into and
around the side chairs many of you will
recognize having sat on plan committee
for some time and having assessed
hundreds of applications planning
officers environmental health officers
and so on do not recommend approval of
applications if there is even the slight
concern in relation to plumbing policy
and technical considerations Indy chair
there are a number of applications
before you this evening which are
recommended for refusal
this chair is recommended for approval
the company has an excellent working
relationship with the planning
department and as I stated earlier
respond immediately should any
representations be made by any members
of the public and for that I'd like to
thank them chair goes without saying I'm
sure in the run-up to and post brexit we
will be entering on certain times SI t
roof space is a company that is and will
make a positive contribution to the
economy through job creation and
increased productivity which can only
have a benefit to the local economy
members please ask any questions if
there's anything need clarification on
before and I genuinely hope that you
uphold the recommendations of the
planning officer and grant consent for
this extremely important application
thank you Jeff
thank you any questions councillor bombs
it did appear from what the objectives
if you like and the parish council said
that they got a phone number they can
ring well I'm saying that they appear to
be in contact with you we have the main
number on the website and we don't give
out mobile numbers but I would have no
problem issue my mobile number to local
resident if that was felt necessary they
appeared to be communicating with you
yeah absolutely
how do they do that I think it's through
our office how about emails previously
from local resident but I think comes to
our office or main number yeah okay
Richards um the hours seem rather
excessive and excessively late to me
what do you why do you need that just
for my clarity and how are you going to
manage the light pollution to residents
and particularly the noise from vans
lorries coming on and off site and being
loaded so the first one about it was
about the really the reason for the
increase so the moment is just purely
demand our client base
at the moment we're looking at cuz we've
got the facility and asset in the
business we've obviously got the ability
to extend it so that was number one that
we just want to increase our numbers in
terms of how it's going to affect in
loading what we've actually looked to do
then is the recommendation to go to a
nine o'clock that's going to work inside
and basically what we're doing in
external yard is just moving materials
raw material from the yard to the
factory there is no loading in the
evenings so all the loading and wagons
and Arctic vehicles is in the working
hours of the eight o'clock til six
o'clock that we've currently got so the
only reason for the evenin is so that
we've got access through materials into
the factory for the evening work and the
lights so at the moment the
recommendation is to go to an either
o'clock that's just for spotlighting why
the fall lives to work in that yard area
soon as 9 o'clock they'll be switched
off there before tea so any any one
after nine o'clock that happens to be in
and out will have to work in darkness
that we know be outside in the yard
after 9 o'clock so it's only internal
work will be happening nor non reloading
after nine o clock there'll be nothing
happening at all sticking together yeah
trustus okay the question on one of our
conditions something you raised about
extra storage we've got the extension
hereby permitted shall only be used as a
noise airlock which seems to be the
positive aspect of it and shall not be
used for storage or any manufacturing
are you I'll be changing and yeah I
think the reason we've said that is in
the past it was almost suggested that by
putting things in the way it just has an
additional barrier to noise so at the
moment we'd do that purely if there's to
an assistance but we don't require it
for storage okay thank you and I also
noticed I think in the report it says
it's only for forklifts there's entrance
but it's going to cover an existing
pedestrian access so will this be used
for people to come in and out of or only
the for beverages no it's only for the
for this so that little door lends the
Emergencies fire exit that we have to
have in play okay and a third one go on
council Richards questions you're only
using the fog lifts
for moving things in and out into the
factory presumably not for loading H TVs
but you you do have a in your plan to
deal with stopping Laura's parking on
the a 435 you have a telephone number
for late arrivals so that the gate can
be opened after nine o'clock presumably
the lights will go on at that point
the gates will be closed at nine o'clock
there's no access to the business after
nine o'clock so okay thank you up to
nine o'clock it's external work in the
art no deliveries at nine o'clock then
the gates are shut
okay thank you we could deal with that
later
gents no thank you very much and we now
have cancer Adams counselor for Ulster
as you know you have five minutes and
I'll give you 30 second to the committee
regarding changes to this site the
original change of use from v8 storage
and distribution to Class B to general
industry was granted under delegated
powers by an officer in October 2014
there has been two applications for
variation of conditions September 16 and
September 17 both these granted although
objected to by the residents on myself
it seems that the big roof space has
have never been happy with what they've
asked for and have obviously outgrown
the site the site is on the main one of
the main routes in to Oslo and opposite
a site that contains an important listed
building a beach in court and is one of
the Oscars for Churchill monument
monument sites and it's green it's in
Greenbelt and fully screened as per the
officer's report the applicant was
required to submit sir
escaping scheme to enhance the
landscaping treatment along the Berman
Road
the officer acknowledges that at the
time of writing the report the applicant
was in breach of this condition as they
had not submitted a scheme within the
required time frame I have serious
concerns with the proposed increasing
working hours and the impact it will
have on the residents of King's cotton
it is an increase of 31 working hours
per week at the moment they can look
forward to spending a quiet evening in
their gardens without the noise from the
factory traffic through studly Kings
Cohen thinks at around 8 a.m. then again
at 5 p.m. the traffic levels fall very
quickly after that and much less road
noise is produced in the evening the
factory noises from see that these
quieter times have a much bigger impact
and yet sig wants to carry on working
into the night factory noises during
quiet hours have greater potential to
disturb local residents but you've heard
the sound report based on 2015
measurements suggests that it is
unlikely that residents will be
disturbed by noise introduced by the
forklift trucks around the site yet
residents can hear the forklift noises
the sound report does not seem to give a
true picture of the real situation the
sound report has a final disclaimers
statement giving no guarantees of the
fire final impact assessment due to the
translucent nature of the environmental
sound levels the sound report is out of
date inappropriate for the present
application and needs to be redone the
SDC environmental officer highlights his
disappointment that the noise reports
emitted is based on a previous report
and not live acoustic information and
would like I can't consolidated acoustic
reports emitted with the proposed
increase in working hours the officer
has asked for a revised lighting plan
and this is supported by the
environmental of
and it is one of the conditions but with
the number of enforcement notices issued
to the country for non-compliance of
conditions can we please make sure that
the lighting scheme is agreed or
monitored before new working hours start
the company needs to restore confidence
in the local community by not expanding
further we've got 15 residents from
King's token here tonight there's been
38 letters of objection with a further
10 on the update sheet and this includes
that ultra civic society you've heard
the objections from ultra town
councillor and myself can I ask you to
defer your decision until an up-to-date
sound report and lighting scheme is
received or reject this application
because of the impact it will have on
the lives of the residents of King's
fountain and the site is unsuitable for
extended working hours thank you thank
you very much any questions
counsel Richard thank you and thank you
for that council so the area will see
lies within the also special landscape
area can you tell me a little bit about
whether the street lighting and the
vicinity of this site or generally in
the in that area can you confirm to me
whether there is or isn't any street
lighting in and around this area so
through a store through the surrounding
area
I've I think we'll have to leave it with
cancer Adamson and maybe Oscar on Isis
on clarity from Kessler bombs it's I
don't know whether you had any liaison
with the company but the residents that
spoke seemed to have done it the way you
found it or the way you speak is just a
bit of a problem we have a locally a
zone committee or a group or a phone
number
we shouldn't appear at the moment to be
in force that might help if the
application will be approved counselor
did you wanna speak no no more questions
okay thank you very much
and now we can go to technical questions
the officers remembering that we do have
Paul Reid from environmental health as
well can't sort of Richards could you
confirm whether their street lighting in
the area in this special landscape area
looking at these photographs here this
is near the entrance this is on the
Elster Heath road so it doesn't like it
thank you
the I'll start with the there was a
suggestion that there had been some
complaints made about breach of planning
control can you confirm whether we have
or haven't had any of those and if we
have have they been upheld we have had
condition notices
the site three notices that we had saved
I assume that they have now been
ratified by the applicants and a to
longer okay thank you okay understood
so in terms of the lighting I'd like to
know a little bit more about that and
and how it can be monitored it sounds
like it's going to be turned off at nine
o'clock
have we assessed the impact that it's
going to have on residents the local
residents particularly and similarly
with noise do we have an understanding
of the sort of noise that is created by
working inside the factory and how it
would likely impact the residents thank
you through the chair if I can take them
the other way around
noise yes we have an understanding with
regard to what noise is generated and
what impact is that is likely to have on
the local community and indeed the
extension as it provides an acoustic
Lobby it's going to be a first
significant benefit to the local
residents for a noise break out from the
factory point of view however that the
yard noise itself is a different entity
it's external it is going to impact on
the local community they will hear it
will they hear it sufficiently for it to
be an actionable noise nuisance under
environmental health legislation from
what the report is saying it's saying no
that's not going to be the case is it
going to be ideal from a planning point
of view this is where environmental
health officers would expect the best
possible result from from the factory
what the factory noise impact on a local
and will I hear is yes they will until
nine o'clock is that going to be
sufficient to prevent or disturb
sleeping I would say not internally
but externally that definitely has the
potential the reason for asking for a
consolidated noise report is really to
bring into play the internal elements
and the external elements together
taking into account is there going to be
more production or not is the impact
levels from various noise sources inside
the factory still relevant
there could be an improvement in the way
that the factory operates and that
improvement isn't reflected in in the
noise report as it stands more likely
however it could be that the factories
work output could detrimental impacts on
a local community and they may not be an
improvement in fact it could be the
other way around
it could be more noise the reality is I
don't know because the noise report
doesn't go that far and doesn't
consolidate both okay you want to follow
up so in your expert opinion well it's
probably wrong way to put this but I'm
trying to wrestle in my mind whether I
feel that we should be deferring pending
and up to date and the appropriate noise
assessment because I do feel there would
be there is a likely impact to the
residents and I want to make sure that
I'm satisfied and you as our
professional environmental health
officer is satisfied that it's not going
to be - such a significant extent that
we should be refusing this that make
sense
thank you I'd agree with you and and
hence why I said that in my report back
a consolidated report takes away any
ambiguity or any guesswork and gives us
a firm base to base our comments on to
date we haven't got that can we move on
to councilor prey
sort of question and I was leaning
towards a deferral but we can well
unless anyone's going to propose a defer
that we don't actually share obviously I
know this site better than everybody
else in this room
so if because I've lived in Austria all
my life and I could give a bit of
history on this side we saw what's going
to do okay
any more questions technically a system
of noise is the resistive lighting is
there any monitoring is the District
Council or Environmental Health doing
that so that we can see what the
situation is
as it happened my son many years ago
used to drive for the big company that
worked 24 hours a day there but what I'm
saying who is monitoring it and are we
seeing it okay Louise we've got a noise
machine with the guards to you know ease
that we do have the capacity to install
noise monitoring equipment and that is
solely to assess static nuisance and we
shouldn't get confused with regards to
planning conditions and that is one
standard and statute a nuisance which is
a totally different standard altogether
okay much higher standard okay counselor
pain are we sorta debating over chair
they were still in technical questions
I'm coming in debate we're ready for
debate okay great kenta Richard sirs
have cancer risk and say based on the
professional support we've been given I
do think it's wise for us to defer so we
can fully understand the IMP
of the noise what I would expect to see
is a full noise assessment and following
from that a report that explains how
that noise will be managed to keep it
within appropriate levels and I'd like
to understand a little bit more about
the lighting and how the lighting is
going to be managed okay counselor great
okay before we get into that I think
that's quite quite quite detailed but I
just want to go over with okay before
counterpane speaks had maybe like to get
something from from our environmental
health officer on on that proposal
yes Jer I think that's a sound bass and
that is really what I said and my
comments oh great okay counterpane Thank
You chairman and members I just ask you
to bear with me just for a few moments
because remember we are moving towards
the deferment so we don't only I'll save
my okay so we've had a proposal a second
all those in favor of deferring for the
noise report and the light report
unanimous chairman okay so that's
deferred Thank You councillor
okay we're just gonna adjourn for a
couple of minutes while I think Kings
cotton leaves the building
okay back on track application 1703 76
to land ejector 385 Birmingham Road
stratford-on-avon and David million ship
we'll be explaining this one thank you
Thank You chairman the application site
is denoted by the black dot as you see
on the screen it's to the north of the
tyre of Stratford upon it in the
built-up area boundary the application
site is enclosed by the black line here
orange dots in the middle it's the
actually form to the north eastern half
or thereabout a very deep but fairly
narrow plot the axis is on to Birmingham
Road the existing site is now surrounded
by a modern housing development on all
sides to the north I think is a bovis
development that still being built out
this properties here I think a known as
hares leap and I think they're squirrel
Street at the front there and to the
side slightly older development but
still modern is worth sway and for
comparison this is a 1999 aerial photo
that shows obviously that at that time
it was a much more rural setting and you
see the row of trees there they are they
are protected trees predominantly lime
trees but I think one or two Oaks and
this one here t1 which is colored in
yellow is proposed to be removed and
that's a lime tree the top photo here
shows the existing gated access that
access is directly onto Birmingham Road
and the bottom photo is a view from
within the site showing a couple of the
tpo trees looking north east this is a
site layout so we have the dwelling here
broadly in line with the houses on
either side with the access parking in
turning area to the front domestic
garden to the rear and you see there
that says t2 so t1 is proposed to be
removed it is worth noting that there
was a patio area that extended towards
tree t2 during the course of the
application this this has been removed
been taken off here we have the proposed
elevations so it's a fairly suburban
modern design very in character with the
the adjacent buildings and the adjacent
modern housing developments and there's
some more site photos here from February
2018 the photograph here I'm hovering
over this is the rear of the neighboring
property to the north of squirrel Street
and this is the rear and side elevation
of the property known as 285 Birmingham
Road which is actually accessed off
Worth's way and these other two photos
here are looking down the site
respectively this this photo here is
actually the rear section of the site
that is is actually not proposed to be
developed at this point and here are
some site photos taken more recently so
showing the trees in leaf top photo
there from Birmingham Road the photo
next to it also from Birmingham Road
it's this tree at the front that is t1
which is proposed to be removed on this
bottom photo here from squirrel Street
it's I think that tree or possibly you
can't see it maybe just off there and
here are some photos from the adjacent
bovis development this real street
that's actually hares leap at the front
to just give you an idea of the
proximity of this row of trees to the
new housing development to the north
and this bottom photo here that is the
property a squirrel Street that faces on
to Birmingham Road so the new dolly will
actually in fill that gap there you have
to help me out here I have a video which
is taken from squirrel clothes
I've actually labeled it this time as
well so this is from in front of the
most recent dwelling just panning across
so you can see there that where the
property is proposed to go there is a
fairly established line of buildings now
modern dwellings quite suburban in
character I think that that shows the
site quite well back in there as you go
full screen Dale and the officer
recommendation is to grant planning
permission subject to the conditions
listening officer report there was a
fairly minor update with regards to the
wording relating to community
infrastructure levy and the weight of
the emerging stratford-upon-avon NDP
policies and that's the end of the
presentation thank you very much
we don't seem to have any speakers
unless we have counselor house ah
which we don't so we will go to that
can't we just
first of all are there any technical
questions okay one treat cancel
yeah just wintery yeah will you propose
a councillor bonds with the officers
okay we have a proposal in a second all
those in favor of granting you
as German okay thank you okay I found I
have to say this so the committee has
resolved to grant planning permission
for application number 17 zero three
seven six two four okay
so correct me if I'm wrong and but we
have two applications now at the same
property in wooden wuined
they're both at grey mill farm and
they're both for very of condition to
remove to turn them into a proper proper
housing but we'll get that from the
officer so what we're going to do is
have one presentation from Alison and
she will at the end of the joint
presentation which refers to all of them
I believe give a little specific bit
about the first application and then we
will have speakers and technical
questions debate and resolve the first
application I'll go into how we do that
in a minute and then we shall have
another little bit about the specifics
for the next application on the same
site and do the same thing if we need to
have speakers technical questions debate
and resolve that how it and we are going
to do it I believe we are actually going
to have speakers for three minutes and
three minutes on each of those great we
weren't sure until today but now we are
so if we go forward Alison on on this
application which is 1800 533 vary and
1800 5 3 4 very Thank You chairman this
presentation is to cover applications
18 5 3 3 very and 1800 5 3 4 very which
both seek removal of holiday light
conditions at grain mill farm water
Mahlon application reference 1800 five
three three very cancer
two units of holiday accommodation known
as the old George and bullpen an
application reference 1800 five three
four very and sends one unit of holiday
accommodation known as the bolt-hole the
two black dots denote the application
sites the dot to the south is the site
for 1800 five three three and indicates
the position of the Old Forge and the
bullpen which adjoined grain mill
farmhouse itself the northern black dot
denotes the position of bolt-hole grain
mill farm is to the south of water Morin
and located approximately one and a half
kilometers from the main settlement
itself this slide shows the three
holiday let staged in red two of which
the old fort and the bullpen are joined
the side of the farmhouse the bolt hole
is the third property and is located
approximately 190 meters to the north of
the farmhouse and is accessed via a trap
this like this slide clarifies the
position of each of the three units of
holiday accommodation so it shows the
Old Forge and the bullpen as previously
stated adjoining the farmhouse and the
bolt hole
further to the north and the submitted
applications are very applications for
the removal of the holiday conditions
and floor plans of the buildings were
not required in order to validate the
applications and have not been submitted
with the applications the supporting
information submitted with the three
application states that the Old Forge
and the bullpen are three-bedroom
properties and that the bolt hole to the
north has two bedrooms
this slide shows photographs of the Old
Forge and its relationship with grain
mill farmhouse so as you can see it's
closely related to the to the side of
the farmhouse and this slide shows
photos of the front and rear elevations
of the bullpen
this slide shows the relationship
between the Old Forge the bullpen and
grain mill farmhouse the three
properties form a horseshoe shape
fronting onto a paved courtyard with
access to the side of the farmhouse
running through the courtyard the fourth
side of the courtyard is a paved parking
area other than the courtyard the Old
Forge and the bullpen did not currently
have any private amenity space the
buildings are surrounded by closely main
grass and a further application would be
required and if they wanted to create
private garden areas for these
properties there is one update on the
update sheet chairman the recommendation
for this application which is 1800 5 3 3
very and which concerns the Old Forge
and the bullpen is to refuse the
application for the reason set out on
page 44 of this agenda thank you very
much so we will now hear from the parish
council counselor mark McCoy wooden lone
parish council three minutes speaking on
0 533 the Old Forge and the bullpen and
I'll give you half a minute at two and a
half minutes all right thanks for let me
speak I'm not the co-chairman of the
wooden wearing parish council and parish
council are happy to support the
application 533 the property was
renovated over 20 years ago and the
applicant office he hasn't seen
sufficient demand for holiday that's
within that period the development makes
good use of the buildings otherwise
redundant farm buildings under current
planning up it's possible that the
applicant could have got permission now
if they hadn't already been converted
into holiday that's although they're
outside the village boundary Fortin
wearing
they meet the neighborhood plan
requirement of primary housing objective
of the plan to provide sufficient supply
and mix of dwellings and meet the needs
of the community as a bit of a lack of
the smaller two and three-bedroom
properties in what and Rouen and a
longer term rental could be useful to
bring young couples and families into
the village and support the local
community potentially children going to
the school use of public transport
there's a footpath from the property
into the village directly as well yeah
the parish council would like we prefer
to see the buildings being used rather
than emptying left to ruin
we don't believe it would have a
significant negative impact on the rural
economy and if anything it would have a
improvement on the economy with higher
occupancy of the buildings many people
spend at the local shops post office and
things it was also not a particularly
isolated dwelling although there's not a
big community there you've got the grain
mill farmhouse and there are three other
properties enclosed close by to there as
well so it's not completely isolated is
quite a lot a few other houses around
there that's also great thank you any
questions cash the balance this is a
really I have a couple questions the
footpath into the village where what
group does that take from from the
farmhouse wasn't it goes from the from
these properties past the ball toll
across the fields along the river into
the village okay and do you guys have an
neighborhood plan yeah so does the
parish have a neighbourhood plan yes we
do yeah you do
okay so you have and in that
neighbourhood plan do you have a
requirement for these three and four two
and three bed as is yeah we all want to
him
provide a better mix of properties
within the village and there's a lot of
big sort of four or five bedroom
properties and some of the smaller
properties would add I think there's a
good a common desire the only problem we
have here is is the location relevant to
the actual main bit of the village I
mean was there anything about where you
wanted these houses in the parish this
doesn't strike me as being in the
village would you call this in the
village or in the parish or what it's in
the parish rod in the village it's
probably 3/4 a mile outside the village
centre something like that so it's not
with it not within the village it's not
necessarily where we would choose to
build a new house
but it's a good use of an old old
buildings thank you very much any other
questions
no okay thank you kindly and we now have
the applicant mr. Ingram for three
minutes as well if you could hang on a
moment I have some question
okay if you'd like to start that's fine
it's about the three minutes but
apparently there may be a little leeway
on this one
so please I've changed it so there isn't
good that it's right I was told six
minutes to stop I was going to join the
two you see yes you've got to make a
determination of each one yes so if you
give us your three minutes out of thank
you my name is Tony Ingram and I am with
my wife Jenny the applicant for this
variation order we live in gray mill far
majority in this application 1800 533
I'm asking your support to take off the
condition as it restricts us from having
any one to stay over five weeks
restrictions of this nature have been
taken off before with in Stratford
District Council notably 1504 to 1/8 so
it can be done so it is not impossible
to do again this application shares our
water making it impossible to market it
as a business to sell as suggested by
the case officer the holiday let's now
in their 23rd year are no longer viable
as a business as we are being forced to
use outside management totally due to me
and my wife's failing health and
longevity submission shall a cash flow
analysis using holiday homes in
Stratford resulting in a very small
excess over expenditure because of our
inability to manage them ourselves we
have our identified other uses for them
which don't need outside management and
can be operated under a restricted time
license as we have been doing the
council considered considers it not
within policy and he's going to shut us
down the other types of clients are
local people one that is staying at the
moment working in the area that required
local affordable accommodation
and assist there is not as fortunate as
many and those with disabilities as two
units of ground-floor
facilities your Syrian inclusion
Department has visited the properties
and is interested in using them
stratford district not only has a
tourist accommodation industry it's as
businesses allowed to that industry that
require a workforce or requiring
somewhere to stay another reason that
was on the report was it will create
isolated new dwellings in the
countryside remote from services and
facilities we are not remote for
properties plus these three on our
postcode and the distance to the center
of the village compared to the new
uncompleted home choice complex in
wharton is 100 metres nearer and that
got permission please consider these
alternatives together with the
submission of parish council support the
policies that are in place at the moment
don't reflect the needs of many inactive
local community and policy around
holiday cottages is too narrow to cater
for other uses at present policies are
there with a condition or an open market
we want them to be more flexible in
their use over the whole year without a
condition because they will otherwise
have no use at all and become what they
were before
redundant farm buildings as per a
submitted pictures at 30 seconds
the farm will also suffer from a lack of
resources as they assist in the upkeep
of the whole farm I'm here to answer any
questions you may want clarification on
thank you for listening to me thank you
any questions kasia Richards the cash
flow that you varic money provided we
don't get the benefit of seeing that but
I don't need to go into too much detail
it sounds like what you're saying is
that the what you've submitted clearly
demonstrates a very insignificant profit
very minor profit is that before you've
employed the agents to marker and
thing on your behalf or is that after
that is after that's not a spec yeah
okay and and so has this been a trend
that's been happening for some time as
that's shown over six months twelve
months or was it no because we we have
been operating it not for the last
twelve two years as holiday let's we've
been we have been using a license as I
said but it wasn't acceptable yeah I
think that those figures are they're not
real figures are that they are real
figures okay there are real figures okay
they are they are they are figures all
the costings outside castings are from
our costing zakat you know them by
account it's every year to the HMRC the
the only extra bit is the Commission the
linen and the wages for everything else
which in fact if you had added up is
what the profit was before we did it
ourselves and the reason why we can't do
it is our health any other questions
I've got one you mentioned not a similar
property if you've got the number for
that again and where that is
that's 1504 to 1/8
that's even Biddeford on Haven okay
that's that's fine that's great thank
you any more questions
thank you very much Chancellor Norton
Thank You air chairman councillors I'm
here to support this application for a
number of reasons I don't really want to
govern more than what the Parish Council
said but I'm on completely agreement
this is a failing business I've been to
see these properties they have been
remarkably well refurbished but it's
very obvious that due to the location
try to let these out as holily annex is
just not working I have a tremendous
sympathy with the applicant because of
this they have tried and they've failed
now let's look at why we should grant
these the parish council in its
neighborhood plan are looking for cheap
accommodation in if terms of not
affordable but low rent accommodation
these are small buildings they won't
command a big rent they're going to be
around 500 pounds a month if that
because they're small this is exactly
what wouldn't Rome needs it it's
absolutely desperate for this type of
accommodation the applicant made mention
to the new affordable home scheme which
is just about to be occupied I think in
a couple of weeks and I was very
involved in the bids for these
properties and I can tell the committee
there were 35 bids for these 2-bedroom
affordable homes there's plenty of
demand for these and this is a reason
why I think they should be converted
from holiday let's to normal standard
ASP let's there's been some comment
about the sustainability yes it is on
the edge of the ward over parish you've
got to have a car you can walk into the
into the village but you're gonna have
to have a car and everybody who lives in
a rural economy like this or in
relocation you've got to have a car
because there's no other way of way of
getting to and from at your business or
or or commerce the heart of the rural
economy seems to be the mainstay of why
this application is recommended for
refusal for the reasons I've mentioned I
can't see that it was any
whatsoever to the rural economy the
business is failing the buildings will
ultimately fall into disuse and by
granting this planning consent a
committee I think it's the best solution
it's fully backed by the parish council
it's within the neighbourhood plan and
we also have letters of support at least
one letter support from the adjoining
owner thank you Jeff thank you any
questions
no thank you and so any technical
questions the offices to debate coach
Lowe Richards Thank You chair and I
think that's a lot and summed it up
pretty well there it's in my way of
thinking operationally it's as if we
were looking at least it's just rendered
and bands that were going to be
converted now and to my way of thinking
that they would they would be granted
through a class cue almost likely
granted through a class queue
notification certainly our policies
support the conversion of redundant
Barnes into dwelling houses the fact is
these are already extensively dwelling
houses they're just not viable in terms
of a business use we're not introducing
new dwellings to the open countryside so
with the support of the parish council a
neighborhood development plan that has a
requirement to for these type of
housings a clear local need in the
community for this type of housing I am
going to propose that we grant the
application with standards conditions
okay just before we go we've got they're
not I think we might need clarification
on this before we go because I don't
think they are dwellings at the moment
are they yeah I mean you might not but I
do okay fair enough
Kasler bars I've got a lot of support
for full farmers being one myself and
I'm caught up in a second that proposal
that's been made as far as I can see we
get these holiday let's if they can't be
kept up or there's a reason in my area
we have that them into domestic going
so we're not really against policy the
reason that the moment is that the
gentleman you know can't afford to do it
in the respective I mean somebody else
to do it and I think board members happy
parish counselor happy to small houses
you wouldn't build them you couldn't
afford to build them it's a golden
opportunity for small people it's not
far to walk
well they could go by River I suppose
but the point is then I'm caught up it
is second the proposal and could go on
for any length of time but this isn't
both what has happened in my area okay
great can you just reiterate your
reasons there to go against it's a grand
not only reasons I need a reason for
people guidance and coastal suggests we
do need reasons whether it's for or
against sorry so that's that's new but
even if that is the case I'm quite happy
to put the reasons forward as a clearly
identified local need supported by the
neighborhood development plan and that
in my opinion that these are already
dwellings it's a failing business that's
been evidenced and the conversion of
variation to convert to normal dwellings
I'm satisfied okay we have and economic
reasons in my area have been one factor
that has been allowed to have domestic
use until apology let's
I'm sorry chair I'm a slow writer I got
as far as identified local need
councillor Richards and then I lost you
please I think there was even tougher
good for
you can summarize it it doesn't have to
be every wicked only we could just watch
the recording and you'll get it although
I think that's probably easy okay
shall we who did local news in the
neighborhood plan right let's go to the
vote so old conditions okay
conditions so we're just we're just
removing the condition so what do we
vote for we're voting to grant
permission to vary the condition as sets
out in the description of development in
our report is that correct
sure I'm we are voting to grunt
permission without that condition but if
you if you read your report it sets out
at the beginning but you also have to
consider whether any other conditions
are appropriate so I would just like the
flexibility to spend the next 24 hours
questioning whether there are any other
conditions that need to be imposed as a
result of this decision and clear those
with you if we officers consider there
is a need for any additional conditions
I can't instantly think of any I would
just like that flexibility over to my
four hours with the Chairman's agreement
I don't think they're only I think if
there are it's just standard but yeah
I'm entirely comfortable with a
traceability to do that now we're all
happy that's good
so we are voting to grant permission
without that condition for the reasons
set out by councillor Richards and so
all those in favor of doing that all
those again unanimous chairman
okay for those in favor can we do that
again please please for German cover
those against one gem thank you
okay so we have resolved to grant
planning permission without that we'll
have that condition on 1800 5 3 3 so now
we will go very briefly to a little
report on 1800 5 3 4 very Thank You
chairman and it's just one slide just to
show the bolt hole which is the property
that 1800 5 3 for concerns and that's
the one that is set to the north of the
farmhouse and chairman the
recommendation for application reference
1800 5 3 4 very is to refuse the
application for the reason set out on
page 56 of the agenda thank you
they give them up so can we hear again
perhaps from wooden warren if they like
okay you don't have to speak okay yeah
so I think we're agreeing that they're
very similar to the previous comments
mr. Ingram would you like to speak
you've quite welcome to go ahead
following the previous application this
one 1800 534 has the same condition on
it and so the same answers I gave relate
to this one as well great thank you any
questions no thank you very much any
technical questions
oh sorry councillor Norton forgive me
Thank You chair I just will remind the
committee to take note of my previous
observations thank you very much any
questions now any technical questions on
this debate councillor Richards I would
like to propose that we grant the
application for the same reasons I gave
on the previous okay conditions and
we're going to sort their conditions I
have an extra four hours all those in
favor of that for chairman all those
against one chairman thank you very much
so we have resolved to grant permission
for that application without the
condition that's 18 zero zero five three
four thank you very much
and now we're going to application 17
zero one seven four nine four and seven
two zero once and five Oh listed
building consent for the old cottage
books I'd snitterfield and David million
trip in a moment it comes will give us
the presentation on that there you go
sorry about that Thank You chairman I
just remember I can't move that okay so
the application site is denoted by the
black dot it's within the northern
fringes of the village of snitterfield
it's the site and the village are washed
over by the West Midlands Greenbelt and
both are also within the special
landscape area of Arden this is the
application site - noted by the the
black outline you can see here it's an
edge of village location and the built
barrier boundary as defined in the
recently adopted snitterfield
neighborhood development plan runs
broadly along this line that I'm just
tracing here and that is where we
consider the existing domestic curtilage
surrounding the old cottage to be this
is a photo showing the area of land that
is the subject of the application and
the small area in blue there is also
under the control of the applicant but
not part of the planning application the
solid Green Line is the approximate
location of a public right-of-way that
runs into the village from the northeast
and I'll just show a video at this point
which
is that one it just shows that the
setting of the cottage
so the cottage is grade 2 listed
building currently in occupation as a
single dwelling it has 17th century
origins you see there at 2 timber-frame
building so has significance stemming
from its historic and architectural
value and the garage you saw there was
built approximately I think in the 1980s
so it's a modern addition to the
building other than that excuse me
other than that as you could see that
the semi rural setting of the building
has been very well preserved through the
years these are the existing plans so
mainly concentrating on the garage here
which you can see is a single storey
building sat in relative close proximity
to the existing historic building and
there's a floor plan again showing the
relationship between the existing garage
in store and the historic dwelling notes
here there is a very I don't know how to
describe it really there's a very slight
link between the garage and historic
building it's a covered porch area and a
wall with a doorway access through to
the rear garden and so this is proposed
site layout so the proposed development
involves the demolition of the
single-story garage and construction of
a part single and part two-story annex
extension with a slightly larger link
into the historic building the second
aspect of the development is a change of
use of this area of land here so this
area of land covered in red that
proposes to change the use to provide a
parking a turning area to serve both the
cottage and the annex and the use of
proposed elevations so you can see here
the front section of the annex is
single-story with a large glazed gable
and the rear section projects up to
two-story slightly lower in height needs
the existing dwelling but very close you
can see on this side elevation that it
extends slightly further to the rear at
two stories and there's proposed floor
plans note the slightly larger link
extension they're forming a porch and a
small ground-floor WC you've got Lily
living accommodation on the ground floor
with a bedroom and small bathroom on
first floor of the annex and here we can
see the bottom plan that dotted line
there shows approximately the existing
ground level so the proposal for the
change of use to the parking and turning
area involves lowering the ground level
somewhat in order to diminish the impact
of the vehicles the applicant had
supplied the cgi images which I think
fairly self-explanatory you can see on
this one here the slightly look slightly
taller two-story section of the annex in
relation to the existing house and
here's another set of CGI images from
the applicant which shows on this bottom
left-hand corner the existing
single-story garage up against the
larger scale annex building what these
CGI images don't show is of note is the
parking area and these are some site
photos taken earlier in the year see the
arrow is there denotes in the distance
the two-story improbably projects
broadly in this location that I'm trying
to mark out there and on this photo it
would come up to the back here extend
further to the rear this bottom photo
shows basically the landscape view so
the fields to the northeast is very open
very green and open and there's static
carve on there and a building there they
don't fall apart this application and I
believe they are to be removed at some
point in the future some some more
photos the public right-of-way extend
along Brookside which is public highway
up to approximate at this point there is
the entrance into the field which would
also form the entrance for the proposed
parking and turning area authoritative
way runs along this line here and then
alongside Brookside so this is a shared
surface between vehicles currently
accessing the property and users of the
public right-of-way and that's just a
photo looking the opposite direction
it's down Brookside into the village and
this is the existing porch and link wall
that joins the existing historic
building to the single-story garage and
the officer recommendation for the full
planning application is to refuse for
the reasons given within the officer
report and the officer recommendation
for the listed building consent is to
refuse for I believe the single reason
given the officer report there have been
updates with this application we
received an additional letter of
objection and following clarification
from the officer the Parish Council
visited the site and withdrew their
objection with regards to the proposed
parking and turning area so the parish
now fully support the application that's
the end okay thank you and we're gonna
hear supporting from councillor Corrin
Elliot from snitterfield Parish Council
so when you're ready just press the
button the red light goes on you'll have
three minutes and I'll give you a
30-second warning try it now just press
the button yeah that's perfect
thank you okay Smithville parish council
have considered this application very
carefully in the light of the recent
approval of our NDP the age of this
property its closeness to a popular
footpath and that the applicants have
lived in our village for over thirty
years with three generations of family
and wish to continue to do so the
applicants um engaged with us and our
decision to support has been helped by a
site visit attended by the majority of
the parish counselors the committee
planning report references policies b1
b3 and b7 which are responding to local
character neighborhood design guidelines
and preservation of heritage assets
regarding these references the
applicants meticulous work to date in
preserving the existing cottage losses
in danger of falling down is to be
highly commended the conservation
officer acknowledges that the existing
gouges of poor design but would prefer
to leave the garage as it is as her
perception is that this is less harmful
than the proposed annex as NDP actually
states at the base highest quality
modern modern designers to be encouraged
and that the provision of space between
buildings preserve the public view of
open and beyond is desirable the
applicants have addressed this by
setting back the proposed annex into the
existing garden as much as the
restrictions of the curtilage allows the
result is that more theal cottage will
be seen from the public right-of-way and
it opens up the public view towards the
fields English heritage recognises a
need for historical buildings to
continue them for evolution to remain
viable to adapt to current social and
living requirements this should be
considered as a mitigation for the
concerns raised by the conservation
officer indeed b7 of ES and D P includes
and supports changes of use to enable
the appropriate and sensitive
restoration of listed buildings by
trying to ensure that historic asset is
not overly impacted by the development
of the annex by setting it back the
applicants no need to find a solution to
the car parking requirements of higher
our site visit made clear that it was
not possible to locate the three carpet
parking spaces to the rear of the
cottage as the only access would be too
narrow and it would have an unacceptable
impact on the setting of the historic
property parking on the road without a
turning circle at the end of the
cul-de-sac is also an unacceptable
safety hazard
there are many walkers and horse riders
who use this restricted narrow road to
access the popular public right-of-way
the solution ie car parking in the
adjacent agricultural field is
admittedly marginally outside the BUP
however NP pfn at 90 defines engineering
operations is not an appropriate moment
as long as they preserve the openness of
the Greenbelt 30 seconds to that end the
park is of a minimum size and
constitutes the only part of the Jason
field for which the rear change of use
it will not set a precedent as a disease
inconsequential the site will main
agricultural as all structures will be
removed and the land plant is an orchard
the PSD consider the application should
be and can be supported within the
village thank you very much any
questions
we had yes any other questions
councillor Norton Thank You chairman you
mentioned that the majority of the
parish council had had been to see this
and there was no objection I mean how
many of those councillors were involved
in the formation of the the new
neighbourhood plan how many yeah
well all of us passed it okay Paul
here's okay fine yeah that's all right
okay thank you any other questions No
thank you very much and we are going to
hear objections from Cathy Kimberly a
resident who has because there are two
supporters you have up to six minutes if
you would like it and I'll give you a
30-second warning at five and a half
minutes if you can hear me yes do feel
free to speak up that because it's okay
right I'm Kathy Kimberly I'm here in my
capacity as a local resident to register
my objection to the application whilst I
support the work already undertaken on
the renovation of the listed cottage and
support the construction of an annex in
principle the location of the proposed
annex which requires the demolition of
the garage has raised two significant
problems firstly the parking space has
been removed and secondly the annex
obscures part of the public view of the
cottage from the public footpath area
highways initially objected to the
removal of the garage and parking and
said three parking spaces are needed
within the domestic curtilage a turning
circle was not specified the cottage is
at the end of a lane the lane there are
no through vehicles it is very quiet
we've had new houses built in the
village and highways has had no
objection to cars being driven on to
front driveways of the property's parked
and then reversed into the road when
leaving so off-road parking
however the applicant proposes
constructing parking space with the
turning circle in the adjacent field
although highways have no objection
there is a problem the NPP f states that
engineering operations that preserve the
openness of the Greenbelt such as the
car park are not inappropriate
providing they do not conflict with the
purposes of including land in the
Greenbelt the problem is there is a
conflict as this parking area would
become an extension to the domestic
curtilage of the cottage and that is
encroachment and as you know one of the
five purposes of the Greenbelt is to
assist in safeguarding the countryside
from encroachment that don't appear to
be any very special circumstances that
would outweigh this substantial harm to
the Greenbelt through this encroachment
also the hard standing area and the
parked vehicles on an attractive open
area of grassland would detract from the
rural character of the area and the
setting of the listed cottage a similar
planning planning application in rowing
tanam Warrick district for parking for
three cars in a paddock adjacent to a
cottage in 2011 was refused and there
was an appeal the planning inspector
dismissed the appeal for exactly those
reasons change of use to domestic
curtilage would result in encroachment
to the Greenbelt with no very special
circumstances to justify it and the
impact on the rural character of the
area due to the hard standing the
conservation officer has stated an
objection to this proposal with which I
agree as I believe our heritage assets
should have the highest protection and
that includes their settings which are
just as important the setting of the
cottage will be harmed could have
illustration 3 this is the plan of the
landscape lamp landscaping to the left
you can see the cottage and with and in
the middle is the that's obviously the
annex and the landscaping and the car
parking to the right now it's my
personal belief that the annex could be
set back further into the rear garden of
the cottage even if a linking port
between the buildings is retained that
is
nine of the annex might have to be
changed slightly as the garden hedges at
an angle but the listed cottage would be
seen and space would be created for
off-road parking at the side of the
cottage the loss of garden space would
be more than compensated by the new
orchard in the field a welcomed
traditional feature that would enhance
the open view of the cottage I also
believe three cars could be parked in
the space created alongside the cottage
the measurements on the block plan
showed the gap between the cottage side
wall and the field boundary is five
point five meters at the top by the
garden and six point six meters at the
bottom by the road a standard parking
spaces 2.4 meters wide so there is
enough space for two cars side by side
similarly the standard length of parking
space is 4.8 meters to pick two spaces
in tandem would be nine point six meters
well the annex footprint shown on this
plan the footprint not quite reaching
the road is nine point one meters long
so yes
two cars could also be parked in tandem
in this space I believe there is
sufficient space for three off-road
parking spaces adjacent to the College
at the to the cottage if the annex were
to be moved to the rear garden
compensated by the planned orchard for
these reasons I believe the current
application should be refused as
recommended by the Planning Officers
thank you thank you very much
any questions great Casa box it seemed
very complicated to me what you're
saying is if they built if they moved
the garage or the existing garage and
the new proposal back and have the
parking in front yes I mean the garage
is going to go because it's going to be
demolished
if the annex to replace the on the same
footprint as a garage in effect could be
moved back into the rear garden
therefore to concentrate on this
application we have rather than an
application we haven't got any other
questions okay thank you very much thank
you
okay now we are going to hear from the
applicant Emma Anderson and Paul Busby
who presumably there to answer questions
if wanted so the buttons already on you
have three minutes and I'll tell you it
two and a half thank you ladies and
gentlemen of the Planning Committee
we've lived in the village for 36 years
the proposed annex will give you enough
space to house my retired parents the
cottage itself is home to myself and my
partner Andi McConnell my son and Andy's
daughter we purchased the land six
months after we bought the house up
until these points the cottage had no
options for parking provision other than
on a single track at the front from the
1980s built garage has been confirmed as
not being big enough for a modern-day
car in terms of parking safety the
neighborhood plan makes clear the
minimum requirements we've approved
works underway the demolition of the
garage now becomes essential as the
rising ground level is detrimental to
the historic building the conservation
officer raised concerns about the
replacement building in her pre-op
report and this has been quoted
widespread throughout the consultations
without further comments we agree with
the conservation officer that the garage
is unsightly the building relates poorly
to the architectural and historic
characteristics of the existing cottage
the replacement building will enhance
the setting of the listed building the
fundamental building work required to
bring the heritage asset to a stable
transition condition that enables
renovation is massive but enabled by the
fact that we are investing in a home for
our complete family the design is modest
given the size of the original buildings
on the footprint and represents less
than 23% by volume the design and chosen
materials relate to the 1908 and 1929
photos submitted the proposed builders
of high quality in
our images have demonstrated an
extremely low level of impact the
proposed replacement building has
received nothing but support from
neighbors and villages as do our parking
proposals the planning report suggests
that off street parking will be
privately beneficial only we strongly
disagree and would refer to you the
letters of support from our neighbors
firstly for safety reasons once arrived
at the cottage the only way out is is 75
metres to reverse from the road is not
straight and only 10 feet wide the
junction on the Watterson Road is a
blind Bend not forgetting that the lane
is a public right-of-way the walkers and
their doctor at risk when vehicles have
to reverse secondly outside the cottages
the entrance to two agricultural fields
the Lando's owners and the horse owners
need access at all times as to the
utility services 30 seconds finally does
the parking of cars to the front and
main innovation to the cottage not have
a bigger impact on the suburban feel
suggested as surely parking to the side
of the building would be less intrusive
as the views are not so open a
landscaping scheme accommodates this for
these reasons we ask the committee to
approve our application thank you thank
you any questions
Kenzo Lawton thank you Jeff good evening
ever just one question you mentioned
that as existing you're driving 75
meters down the road it is though is the
room at the load to turn a car round or
is all do you have to reverse 75 metres
okay that's fine thank you any other
questions
no thank you very much that's fine
and now we're gonna hear from councillor
britches
can you just turn off the other thanks
before I start I have point a
clarification if I may would you mind
bringing up well first of all members if
you bear in mind what you're looking at
now and they're particularly the green
area and then if you bring up your blue
and red location plan so that blue area
is where the trees are proposed to go so
just for clarity that is a
reintroduction of an orchard that hasn't
been included within your red line that
I believe should have been Bo just
thought I'd clarify that for members
before we crack on you can I know you
can do you can do it later on once we
are doing later on and I just so
notwithstanding that minor adjustment
before you I think is what I consider to
be a well-written and well worded report
that clearly identifies the Bennett's
that benefits the proposal while sort of
also discussing the relevant
considerations however I do not agree
with the conclusions that case offers
come to so I'm trying to explain why the
two main concerns related to green belt
and to harm to a listed building so
exploring the green belt first the case
officer seems to accept in his report
the 23% increase to the building is
acceptable under the paragraph 87 and 89
of the MPP F and indeed of our own core
strategy cs10 but has a concern
surrounding the parking as you've seen
from the photos and also the video there
is that there are existing hard standing
areas in that place and what the
applicant is seeking to do is to
significantly improve that area by
reducing the height of the hard standing
to the same level as the house and then
reintroducing grass with a growth
through matting to provide grit for the
cars and also reintroducing an apple
orchard which I believe significantly
outweighs any harm that may be
identified and could constitute special
circumstances now considering any harm
to the listed building one should
consider the significant improvements
that already been made to bring the
listed building back into it's original
standards significant improvements that
are being taken being made by the by the
house owners
an extreme cost the existing 1980s
garage is as I'm sure you can all agree
and I saw the proposed replacement is a
dramatic improvement on the existing and
would in fact improve the setting of the
listed building its design is in keeping
with the illicit building and other
properties within the village and its
size scale and massing is acceptable
both in its location and in Greenbelt
terms there is concern over the existing
buildings on the site as the case
officer outlines in this report the
applicants have agreed and indeed the
the application seeks to remove those as
part of the application and if it's
something that you feel it needs to be
conditioned then of course you have that
option similarly if your monitors are
ground you could remove PD rights to
prevent those buildings being reinstated
if you felt it necessary it is quite
rare that we have both neighbors and
parish council and wor member flee and
support and I would ask you to approve
this application if you still have any
doubts I would implore you to come and
have a look and have a site visit to
fully understand the extent to which
this parking is a problem and the
minimal impact that this development
will have on the listed building Thanks
so can I ask a quick question
after you mentioned our improvements to
the setting because of the new building
being better than the old building and
before he went to PD what she were
talking about something what was that so
on to the right the building where the
apple orchard looks like I brought you
the ancient orchard is proposed to go
there was the caravan which you saw in
the video and a couple of small stables
at the back they would go as part of
this and you can condition for them to
be removed and for those that orchard to
be caster bumps yes there seems to be an
obviously a problem with parking if you
want to put it that way the inclusion in
the open countryside is a reasonable
refusal but you're saying that the
parking that is proposed will have like
be having conservation areas so plastic
and grass grow into it is that get rid
but that's what that is what was
proposed yes to remove the existing
it's worth bearing in mind that at the
end of that Lane is the entrance to a
farmer's field and now under
agricultural matters I understand and
I'm sure the case office will clarify
this later on and a farmer would be I
would support hard standing to be able
to access his field so that's certainly
a possibility if we're talking about
parking in front of that gate of course
the farmer has no access to his field
causes a conflict in our way and you
have questions cancer prey in your
report you raise special circumstances
but no special circumstances have been
offered by the applicant can you explain
why I can't speak for the applicant
I'm sure if you'd answer that question
to them when they were able they would
have answered it for you
but I think from my point of view very
clearly an improvement to an existing
site and quite frankly a dramatic
improvement to an existing building
isn't itself special circumstances yeah
that's okay thank you very much
so we now go to any technical questions
to the officers councillor Lawton Thank
You Jett I'm just going back to Council
Richard's comments is that right that we
could condition if we were reminded to
grant this that the existing temporary
caravan and stables could be demolished
and not rebuilt and supplementary to
that could we also insist that no
permitted development rights well the
the caravan the the buildings the
caravan is in place at the moment while
as I understand it the house is being
renovated so it currently benefits from
temporary permitted development rights
so we wouldn't need I mean as part of
this application we're not considering
the caravan or the other buildings we
wouldn't need to condition the removal
of the caravan because it will have to
go at some point once the house is at a
point where it can be lived in the
caravan
I think it's 14 or 28 days the caravan
will become unauthorised as I understand
it the buildings there's a kennels and
storage building or possibly two
channels they are unauthorized buildings
in their own right so again we wouldn't
need to use planning conditions as part
of this application to have them removed
that would be a matter to be dealt with
by planning enforcement at a later date
if the informal action didn't bear any
any results in answer to removing
permitted development rights if we were
considering the entire area a change of
use of the entire area including where
the orchard trees have proposed then we
would think if it was acceptable it
would be necessary to remove permitted
development rights for that piece of
land within the curtilage of the listed
building there wouldn't be any permitted
development rights because it's listed
so that's the sort of blanket removal in
itself because we're only considering
the section the change of views on the
area of land to be used as parking and
turning area
I don't think we need to remove
permitted development rights as such but
we would place a condition on to say it
would have to be retained as a parking
and turning area we have almost in
perpetuity I suppose okay before we go
there can we answer and I've got two
people to ask questions can we answer
that question about the red line presume
about the red line and why doesn't it
include the orchard in which case can we
do any conditions about the orchard I'll
answer that in Reverse yes we can we
could in theory condition landscaping
scheme within the orchard area because
it's the blue line now the reason it
isn't within the red line there was a
point when the application was submitted
for the change of use that it was
included within the red line but subject
to meeting the applicant and a architect
on site and some discussing some of our
concerns with the encroachment into the
Greenbelt the area to be proposed as a
change of use to domestic land was
reduced what we'd have to consider is
that if that area
was part of this application we'd be
talking about a much larger encroachment
into the Greenbelt so that's why it's
actually not forming part of this
application so it would not if we grant
the if members decide the parking
turning area is acceptable as well as
the proposed annex and the application
is granted that land would not become
domestic curtilage okay so that that's
good so what about how we can which were
not we're not proposing it but could we
condition those that orchard
if embers chose within the blue line
it's within the applicants control so I
would say yes we could okay thank you so
first of all councillor Barnes well
you're partly out answered my question
in the respect that we can put
conditions on to say that the car park
is kept green and make it and we can
obviously have landscaping if the blue
line is included in the red line if you
want to put it that way is that correct
because they're the reason one of the
reasons for refusal is they can't park
in but we do if we are going to if we
were to propose you know to approve it
we want to make sure that the car park
still green but we have been our
conservation areas like Dawson yes I
mean if members felt that the the scheme
as as a whole was acceptable so
considering the the impact of the annex
on the list of building as well as the
change of use then conditions within
that respect could be recommended we
could include them yeah we could agree
worthy with the the chairman of the case
okay any more questions on that so we'll
go to debate councillor Barnes this
seems to be more about parking than
building to be honest situation was that
lady opposed it really wanted to build
him back further in the Greenbelt so
that was room to park at the front but
we didn't appear to have a solution that
we can park on part of the orchard it
can still be green so I'm quite happy to
propose the applique
for groan counselor Lawton Thank You
chairman
IIIi I agree with counsel Richards is
very well written report
I again disagree with the outcome and I
think it probably is a very finely
balanced decision but my view here is
what is proposed is materially better
than what's there at the moment I think
that the the design of the of the annex
is very very sympathetic and and
certainly the materials and the siting
possibly for my point of view improve
the view of the listed building I would
perhaps agree that the special
circumstances here however is the
improvement of the site itself to
actually have a car parking arrangement
that is workable I believe is a special
circumstance in this instance and I'd be
more than happy to second counsel vans
the proposal that we accept this
planning application nope councillor
bars you happy with those reasons yes if
they I'm not I mean if you haven't got
the conditions now like we did them the
other one yes I'm caught up in it is a
major improvement okay we're just going
to clarify those reasons with Dale the
first one guaranteed that 24 hours
you've got them agreed I'm quite happy
with that but
yes yeah a little clarity would be
helpful I'm not quite sure whether I'm
hearing from members that you regard
that there is some harm to the green
bell that harm is balanced by very
special circumstances there is a
positive benefit and therefore there's
no need to enter the discussion about
whether there are any very special
circumstances or not I think I've heard
both sides and I'm not quite sure which
is the one but that's Carrie
can I just well ok Costa bonds building
there is a problem in car parking
because of the green we can address the
green so basically that's that's great
councillor Norton well yes I mean as I
saying I think that in my judgment on
balance that the improvement to the site
generally is a special circumstance and
far outweighs any minimal damage to the
green belts are you seeing any damage at
all I'm saying that obviously any
developments in the green belt
potentially has harmed but in this case
the balance is very clear in my mind
that what is proposed is better than
what is existing it's getting rid of an
ugly building the the annex is
sympathetics whose building and I
believe it actually improves the the the
the existed listed building okay that
along with the lowered so do we need a
very special circumstance or not okay
great well we've got the very special
circumstance
yeah I think that's it so far just if we
can get on that we are admitting it's a
very very slight Greenbelt
reason for refusal but the the outlying
of the improved parking and the design
and the look of the place over come
we've had the list of building reasons
which is that this this design enhances
enhances the look of the place compared
to the existing so we've had to happy
with the design we can't just want to
get moving back conditions to be agreed
so shall we vote in that case to go
against the officers in this case and
grant permission for this development at
the old cottage oh yes so this is 4 this
is the 1701 749 full application or in
favor of granting sweet German or
against 1 Chairman abstain okay thank
you and now for the so that committee
resolves to grant planning permission
for application 1701 seven four nine
four now we'll move on to the listed
building consent 1701 seven five zero
all those in favor of granting
permission three chairmen against one
chairmen abstain one chairman thank you
very much so this committee resolves to
grant Planning Commission
or 1701 7 5 o LD see okay how long can
we go on for without voting excellent
excellent thank you very much so the
next application is Sunnybank okay
application 1800 499 outline planning
application citibank Charleston Road
wooden Warren and Allison Young is
presenting this
Thank You chairman
this application is an outline
application for the erection of a
dwelling and creation of vehicle access
with all matters reserved except for the
access the application cites lies to the
west of the village of Woodham on and is
identified by the black dot on the plan
the site lies to the northern side of
ulster Road opposite the primary school
to the west of the site is allotment
land with paddock land beyond the
northern boundary the site is washed
over by the west midlands Greenbelt the
pink line on the plan denotes the
boundary of the conservation area which
is approximately 150 metres away from
the site the red shading denotes listed
buildings which again are some distance
from the site here we have an aerial
view of the site which is outlined in
red the allotments are located to the
west and the paddock and to the north
this plan shows the site in more detail
and the land ownership the application
site currently forms part of the garden
area of Sunnybank this application is an
outline with all matters reserved except
for access
therefore this plan shows the location
of the access and indicate the
visibility's bays which are shown as the
red lines this photograph was taken from
Ulster Road with the application site to
the left of the photo behind the hedging
please note that the site is
substantially higher than the road the
design and access statement submitted
with the application states that the
site is elevated approximately two and a
half meters above the level of Ulster
Road the new access is proposed on
towards two Road in a position to the
left-hand side of the photo so in this
sort in this sort of location here
the application site is on the
right-hand side of this photo with the
primary school to the left which is just
outside the photo you see the zigzag
lines
this photo is taken from further down
the Ulster Road with the application
site in the distance on the right-hand
side and the existing property and only
Sunnyside in the foreground of the photo
this photo is taken from within the
application site looking across all to
the road to the primary school this
photo is also from within the site
looking back to the side elevation of
Sunnyside this photo looks westwards
across the Jane a joist in adjacent
allotments psyched and this photo is
taken from from the site looking into
the adjacent paddock to the north
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
the outline application for the reason
set out on page 85 of the agenda Thank
You lovely thank you so now we go to the
parish council of wooden Rowan
councillor
Martin Corrigan who has three minutes
and I'll tell you a two and a half blank
German again I'm Bob McCall chairman of
what and Webb parish council and the
parish councils here today to give their
support to the application with regards
to the Greenbelt and we feel the
development would have little impact on
the Greenbelt
the proposed locations at the bottom of
the hill and although it has neighboring
properties no other properties really
look out onto onto it other than
Sunnybank and they wouldn't obstruct any
views of any of the other properties the
design at the house keeps the ridgeline
lower than the current building at
Sunnybank and
surrounding properties its situated
within the village boundary as defined
by the wooden wearing neighborhood plan
which indicates where the local
community are happy to see new buildings
the location the property is on the
Ulster Road and we feel it therefore is
in fill between sunny Bank and the Toll
House on the other side of the world
mere road and the Ulster Road actually
goes around the corner and up the hill
there on the west hand side you just got
the allotments but to the side of the
proposed development and the railway
line and so there's not really any scope
for any further developments to the west
should the application be granted
there's been a lot of support from local
people in the community neighboring
properties and the parish council take
all those views into account with their
decision as well and we feel it's
important to support this application
areas which have been outlined in the
neighbourhood plan where we allow infill
in the green belt yeah just for clarity
and that is this one of those areas yeah
this is one of the areas is inside the
village boundaries defined by the
neighbourhood plan yeah
thanks to bounce to me it doesn't look
like into the the Ulster Road goes
around the corner there and and south so
that the property there isn't another
property on the left-hand side
that's actually going up going to be a
road rather than Ulster Road yeah any
other questions
No okay thank you and we are hearing
from mr. Clive Cory the applicant Lang
who also good evening also has three
minutes and I'll tell you a two and a
half just makes things easier
okay good evening my name is Clive Corey
and I'd like to address the committee
about my planning application the
committee report recommends that you
refuse this however the report does
agree that the proposed development is
acceptable in this location and I quote
it would not harm the appearance in
character of the area accordingly there
is no disagreement on the principle of
this proposal the report does rule out
development as a brownfield site but
acknowledges that development would be
permitted under policies applicable to
limited infilling in local service
villages so this report then goes on to
argue that the proposed development
would not meet its definition of limited
infilling however I will demonstrate
that it is limited in filling and for
the following reasons each should be
permitted I've produced some slides and
the slide shows that the plot does in
fill a gap between houses on the Ulster
Road the report openly acknowledges that
there is no definition of limited in
filling and case law makes deciding this
point a matter of judgment by you the
decision-maker so when you come to
consider this you should do so not by
strictly bate be back to the the
definition used in the report but you
should look at limited in filling in the
context of this particular application
giving full weight to the neighbourhood
plan now policy h1 and the explanation
in the neighborhood plan simply refers
to limited in filling as in a small
infill development on land within the
village boundary without any further
qualification the slides illustrate how
the proposal in fills in a ribbon of
continuous development in the village
boundary along Ulster Road between my
home sunny Bank and my neighbors at
tollgate cottage and then on to 14 other
houses are there as the road climbs
upwards towards Ulster I'd also like to
highlight core strategy 16 C and an I
quote the council is committed to giving
local people the opportunity are known
dead here so
local local people the opportunity I
come using my time nursery giving local
people the opportunity to influence
where homes are built in their
communities the parents council has
exercised its planning judgment in the
context of the neighborhood plan and
overwhelmingly supports the proposal
indeed the parish council have made
representations today since summary my
planning statement and the evidence
before you clearly demonstrates that the
proposed development constitutes living
limited in filling and a court with
Greenbelt policy and a neighborhood plan
by supporting my application the
committee will be seen as upholding its
policy for greater local influence and
inclusiveness the absence of any third
party objections also indicates wider
community support and the report itself
recognizes that the proposal would not
harm the appearance and character of the
area and it also is much needed housing
wouldn't Rowan thank you very much -
delicious thank you very much you gave a
description or a definition of what you
determined infill I have an idea and
there's also something in our report
could you just go through what you said
again because I think it accorded with
what we have so limited in filling it
isn't defined it was defined in legacy
guidance for when the framework was
introduced that that was repealed under
annex 3 I've been a lot of research in
this and so there's a lot of case law
and ultimately when it comes to deciding
what limited in filling is it's a matter
for the for you the decision-makers
there isn't a definition so that the the
report actually refers to the old legacy
definition but that was repealed under
annex 3 to the national policy framework
and so what he's limited in feeling is
up is up to you the committee to decide
but according to the the definition
that's written in the village plan it
simply says that
filling is I've got to find it now
small infill development on land within
the village boundary and it doesn't
qualify it to say there has to be any
other factors that's what I thought you
said and it's not far from what I wrote
down is mine okay thank you any
questions that I've got got just a again
a clarification the Ulster road goes
back towards the main road yes a bit
further up it seems to become wave wave
and spawns new road no yeah well oh I
see it bends round the bends around yes
and to be honest I think that the
planning officer miss this when they
were when she was at the site she was
only that's the infill you're talking be
at the infield is between my house and
you can see the arrow to tollgate
cottage yes and then on again that's
clarifies it that's right thank you very
much that's great thank you so now we're
going to hear from councillor Lawton
Thank You chairman councillors again I'm
here members to to completely agree with
the parish council and I fully in
support of this application just one
point of clarification you probably
haven't driven down this part of the
Ulster Road but that spur its which is
one's way but it's effectively a
t-junction the Ulster Road is parabolic
it's a curve you do have to stop just in
case somebody's coming down Warren's
Mill Road they're quite friendly a lot
of people don't it probably needs a
little bit highways work on it but
that's out of the scope of this so this
is a Greenbelt issue that's all what it
is is there any harm
is there any substantial harm by
building one rather attractive dwelling
in an infill site in wooden one it's in
the built-up area boundary there's no
effect on the conservation area which is
some way to the right of this it's part
of an existing street scene and I think
this is why the parish council in their
neighborhood plan decided to designate
this area as potential for development
in the Greenbelt and I think that weighs
very heavily because this is what local
people want we had a similar application
for some affordable housing in the
Greenbelt in wooden one that was
fiercely resisted by the Planning
Officers but this committee or the
majority of it managed to get that
through we've now got a very very highly
successful scheme I see no difference in
this so we must be consistent this free
clean it is there's a school opposite
there's a couple of houses on on this
side of the road it just seems to me to
fit so again we've got 4pc support we've
got no objections whatsoever
it's earmarked in the neighborhood plan
for development it would cause limited
harm to the area the village does it do
need smoke more more houses that's
that's well well evidenced so there we
are I think that we could oh I would ask
you to go against the officers
recommendation and you can cite
neighborhood plan policy h1 and core
strategy policy 16 thank you Jeff
thank you very much any questions
councillor Barnes is in the respective
sustainability how far is it from the
railway station I think you could make
it in about a minute on foot and you
have a question less than a minute no
okay thank you very much
technical question it's to the offices
no debate councillor Richards and so
there's a couple of things that I'm
trying to wrestle with at the moment in
in the literal sense of infill one would
argue that it should an info site would
be between two already built houses the
guidance were given is based on
frontages however within the wooden
warren no word Volm plan they've clearly
identified infill as within the built-up
area boundary so do I which one of those
in fills do I go for or do I consider
that there is harm to the Greenbelt in
by the very nature there's development
but my special circumstance is that the
Neighborhood Development Plan have
identified this as a site for
development and indeed their infill
definition which doesn't necessarily
accord with ours but they're in film
definition is within the built-up area
boundary which this is and therefore is
acceptable because of that special
circumstance we hadn't have accepted
their neighborhood development plan if
it was in conflict with our own
therefore I can only determine the
infill is actually accepted so I'm
inclined to grant because I believe this
to be infill however if that's it for
concern to officers then I'm quite happy
to have that as our special circumstance
surrounding the did that make sense if
did no centralizers want to ask me
questions as I would prefer you chose
this to be infill and we therefore
didn't need to go down the Queen
Bellwood but I don't have officers how
many cones
take a look so to the Richards so I
think on balance because we've accepted
a neighborhood
development plan that identifies in fill
as within the built-up area boundary I'm
quite happy to say this actually is
infill and this as a second reason is
actually supported by the neighborhood
development plan in terms of its
location etcetera etcetera
okay any other debate encroachment into
the green it's not a formally developed
site and it doesn't mean that exception
wrong and I think we should protect the
Greenbelt it should offer greater
protection of the Greenbelt it's in
their policies and we given it
permission twice three times tonight and
there we go again
so I think we should protect the
Greenbelt this is quite an open site
I've had a look at it it's quite open
when you come to the bottom also Road
where the stops on it you look across
it's quite open in new mpps guidance why
I asked the question was that we do
allow group development in Greenbelt if
it's sustainable next to the railway
line you know the Birmingham could
develop along the green green green belt
along Fromelles would in our area
because they're saying well that's if
it's sustainable which light green if
it's not sustainable it's dark green so
in that respect as far as I'm concerned
I could give it a whirl and any other
any other comments so we had a looking
for a second unless you'd like to say
something else suggested that it's not
an exemption in fitness in itself an
exemption I absolutely support the need
to protect the green belt and I've sat
before this committee many times
attempting to do exactly that in my ward
but in this instance there is an
exemption either either way you cut it
whether it's
identified as infill or a special
circumstance because wouldn't Warren
have identified it as infill within
their neighborhood development plan it
falls into an exemption so if that helps
you with making up your mind I think
anyway thank you for that that's very
good very good
can we find a seconder for the proposal
we have to grant this okay so we're
gonna we've got a proposer and a
seconder we've got a reason yeah mainly
that it's infill and that it's
sustainable we're looking there for
conditions stand the conditions to be
agreed we have we're happy with that
proposer so can we vote we up we are
proposing to grant this application I
said all those in favor
unanimous chairman lovely
so this committee has resolved to grab
planning permission on 1800 499 outline
okay so now we're going on to
application 1800 1800 which is nine
bored entice stratford-on-avon and Sarah
McPherson will tell us about this if we
can have some quiet in the committee
please Peter actually can we just hang
on for a minute yeah we're going to
adjourn for one minute thirty seconds
okay okay thank you so let's let's thank
you so the application now before
members is for the proposed direction of
a boundary fence to the rear of nine
board in place and for the erection of a
detached studio this application is part
retrospective and as before the
committee as the applicant is related to
a member of staff the application site
identified here by the black dot is
situated on broad board in place off
evesham Road to the southwest of
Shepherd on Aven here the application
site can be seen entered in red the site
is outside of a conservation area as
indicated by the dotted pink line the
blue line shows the nearby shuddery
Brook I've seen on this plan the
application property is semi-detached
and backs onto Garak way to the rear the
proposed studio is outlined in red and
the fencing is situated behind the
studio along the rear boundary the red
block seen on the map has previously
been removed the plans for the studio
can be seen here including access via
the rear garden and a roof Lantern as
members will see the fencing screens the
studio from the rear the floor here the
studio can be seen from the sides with
the fencing and the floor plan here
shows the triangular shape and the
dimensions of the studio
as members will see from this photograph
the fencing has been erected and the
studio is substantially complete it is
to be rendered with a chalk finish this
is the studio when viewed from the
garden prior to rendering as shown by
this photograph of the host dwelling in
its neighbor a chalk finish is
appropriate to the surrounding area here
is development as seen from Garak way
demonstrating that there are parking
areas to the sides rather than garden
here they prepared the development can
be seen on approach to Garak way and
here in the opposite direction this
final slide shows the selection of art
buildings which can also be seen from
Garak way in light of similar
development within the street scene I'm
off the opinion that the development
will not result in significant visual
harm to the character and appearance of
the area there are no updates and it is
recommended to grant the application
with the conditions set out in the
report I think we have no no speakers no
councillor Giles some some some very
pertinent technical questions please
cancer brain general I just want to beat
cancer Richard this is like just a
minute if this wasn't related to a
member of the staff it would be done
under delegated yeah so can I recommend
that we grant permission so you think we
should draw out the technical questions
a little technical questions no our
second Oh are we are ok so we've gone to
debate we've had a proposal we've had a
second
thank you all those in favor of granting
unanimous chair great so we have
resolved to grant application 1800 889
for wonderful and that's the end of the
planning applications but we do have a
little bit of extra business on start
time of meetings I'm happy with 6 is it
does anybody we have 6 15
ah nice but I'm happy with six six is
great
I don't know so I propose we stage six
second - I think they have a second
second
unanimous thank you Mike
oh good good good good any business
extra biscaia formula RT council cargle
is our chairman previously was going to
be seeking support from portfolio holder
and the planning department on us being
able to go straight to the vote on
people have objected but not bother to
turn up
could you pursue that please look into
that yeah look into it and find that we
couldn't do it but I shall I shall um I
should look in it the way we deal with
it is pretty brief anyway did you want
to say something on that okay I did
advise on it like I remember my voice so
I think advances yes it's far as
committees being unreasonable then we
have an issue but if you're not then I
have no issue with it at all so the way
we do it you know you can go straight
about it's a periscope but we have to
listen to me to the proposal the
presentation yes my only concern is that
we there could be a point at which we
assemble a committee which requires a
lot of people a lot of time applicants
will come along and then all of a sudden
there's an objection that's been put
forward and no one shows up it's a waste
of all our time and it actually is a
detrimental cost to if we can
automatically delegate it without us
even basically if we that would be ideal
yeah I don't think that's gonna be
possible that it may well be that we can
just go straight to the vote without
having to go through 25 minutes of have
you say no should we go back once right
why don't you ask me the question again
and we'll have another look at it okay
so I'm asking you the question again but
not today
no I look at it okay thank you thank you
bye-bye
[Applause]